rated M for Mature  [Music]  hello there  I'm out looking for my people seven of  them to be exact  maybe you've seen him a couple of farm  boys in an old man Spanish guy and his  daughter big black guy in a pretty  little pregnant lady let's just say we  had our differences  we have to leave now sweetie before he  comes back with more bad guys  Carlos will be following us what's the  most important thing in this world  what's the one thing a guy would walk  hundreds of miles to keep  you have no idea  people are to you  and people don't trust you how can you  trust them everyone I grew up with  it's gonna happen us  can you chew them much noise there are  only two let's take a  you  [Music]